TV shows may be seen as small-scale siblings
to movies, but they require just as many cast
and crew to tell their own stories the best
way possible.
That means writers, actors, camera operators
and crew members working in perfect unison.
Unsurprisingly, things don’t always go as
planned – but the viewers get to enjoy the
results all the same.
Here are Screen Rant’s Biggest Mistakes
in Popular TV Shows.
Lost
One look at modern television shows just how
much ABC's Lost changed the game, delivering
clues, hints, twists and massive conspiracies
from week to week.
As a result, fans regularly re-watched the
early episodes to see just how much they'd
missed.
Online discussion exploded when viewers took
a closer look at the pilot episode, as the
survivors of Oceanic Flight 815 took cover
from an exploding jet engine.
Specifically, the swooping black object that
seemed to trigger the explosion.
Was it the island's smoke monster?
Another creature yet to be revealed, or the
mystery that would explain all others.
The showrunner were finally forced to explain
that it was only a mistake: an error in the
CG effect.
Fans had to look elsewhere for answers.
Firefly
It may have lived for less than a single season,
but that didn't stop Joss Whedon's Firefly
from becoming a cult hit.
In the years since it originally aired, fans
have had no choice but to watch their favorite
adventures on repeat, learning every detail
and building a series' worth of fiction out
of a handful of episodes.
But we're willing to bet one mistake might
have slipped by.
The pilot episode is capped off by a deadly
escape from a ship full of murderous Reavers,
due mainly to the skills of the crew's pilot,
Wash.
When the ship is home free, Wash relaxes - but
it's clear that he's only *pretending* to
be gripping the steering wheel.
He may steer the ship with his mind, but the
episode also shows he relies on crew members,
not gas, to run the ship's mule.
Supernatural
When dealing with demons, exorcisms and magic
hexes, some mistakes are bound to happen.
Most of Supernatural’s errors are easy to
miss, but a few are easy to spot for those
paying close attention.
When Sam and Dean Winchester are tracking
down a haunted painting in the first season,
Dean gets his brother's attention with a different
name - not the character's, but actor Jared
Padelecki's.
A slip-up that small is one thing, but the
brothers cast serious doubt on their exorcism
skills when chasing a demon onto a commercial
airliner.
Deciding holy water is too extreme to detect
a demon in flight, Sam has a better idea.
Actually, it’s “Deus.”
Not only is “Christo” the word for Christ,
not God, it's Greek, not Latin.
Thankfully, the demon apparently didn't know
the difference.
The Big Bang Theory
When the cast of your show is described as
a group of know-it-all geniuses, writing the
script becomes a minefield of inaccuracies
that could truly sell the characters short.
It’s possible that Sheldon could misquote
the rules of feeding Mogwai after midnight
in the movie “Gremlins”.
But hearing Amy explain that the Viennese
Danish was invented in Denmark makes it clear
that another fact-checker was needed on set.
But even within the show’s history, the
writers have forgotten, or simply ignored
prior storylines.
As just one example, the hypochondriac Leonard
can’t drink wine, except for the times he
does.
And even more dramatically, Sheldon tells
Penny early on in the series that none of
his roommates know how to dance, later breaking
out his best moves that he apparently mastered
in his youth.
The cast may claim to have flawless memories,
but it seems the writers can’t keep up.
Breaking Bad
When series creator Vince Gilligan decided
to set his tale of a chemistry teacher turned
drug kingpin in the year 2007, he did it knowing
that some pop culture references would be
off the table.
For most of the series, the timeline was simple
enough to follow, with time in the show passing
much slower.
But that led to one particular mistake in
the show’s fifth season, when a character
made a direct reference to the death of Osama
bin Laden.
Unfortunately, the show was still set in 2010
at the latest – several months before bin
Laden’s death took place.
The creator had to admit it was a mistake,
but in a show with so few, it can be forgiven.
Buffy the Vampire Slayer
For every actor in a given shot, there are
dozens of crew members and camera men working
just off screen.
It’s no surprise then that that some will
wander into frame from time to time.
Viewers may be shocked to see just how many
crew members slip by unnoticed, but one cameraman
on the set of Buffy the Vampire Slayer stuck
out worse than almost any other.
When the show’s fourth season saw Buffy’s
longtime nemesis Faith wake from a coma and
seek revenge at the Summers house, a fight
broke out, with the two Slayers quickly coming
to blows.
The camera tracks them both as they go tumbling
down a staircase, before the opposite angle
shows the cameraman responsible for the previous
shot, impossible to miss on screen.
Different editions of the show have been tweaked
to keep him out of frame, but with a cameo
this glamorous, we say he deserves a supporting
actor credit.
Friends
You can’t stay on the air for ten seasons
without re-using a few plot lines or jokes.
But usually, it isn’t the same characters
caught up in them.
When Chandler and Monica wind up waiting for
a table at an upscale restaurant, she suggests
Chandler slip the host a bill slyly concealed
inside his palm.
Chandler can’t pull it off, but suspects
it was no problem for Monica’s suave ex-boyfriend
Richard (played by Tom Selleck).
That’s exactly where she learned the trick
– but Chandler should know that.
After all, it was Richard who taught both
Chandler and Joey to do the same five seasons
before.
Chandler forgetting the steps is fine, but
the writers feeling such a tiny joke was worth
telling twice is the real mystery.
Battlestar Galactica
Few sci-fi revivals can claim to be as successful
as Battlestar Galactica, with the second season
of the series ramping up the tension, stakes,
and drama substantially.
Character deaths and betrayals were everywhere
– apparently, the crew thought viewers wouldn’t
notice some hilarious mistakes amid all the
chaos.
When Helo and the Chief first let off steam
by throwing some punches, they did so with
an audience.
Why the camera crew visible in the frame was
necessary for the shot is a mystery, but it
wasn’t even the most obvious mistake in
the season.
When President Roslin was re-elected, her
campaign staff didn’t even notice the cameraman
capturing the moment for viewers to witness
all the way back on Earth.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any great mistakes or bloopers
in your favorite TV shows?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.